when I was in college got a DUI I had to
volunteer at Noel folks home they were
98 I was hungover we were exactly the
same vote just shuffled down the hallway
in our pajamas some old ladies like
when's the pain gonna end I'm like I
know right
she's like they took away my license I'm
like same here
she's like I got an STD in this place I
was like yeah my bad
it's drinking for you it's fun but it'll
get you into trouble my friend got
really drunk one night blacked out
hooked up with somebody got herpes yeah
so he quit drinking kept the herpes but
but booze was our whole relationship now
every time we hang out he wants to do
activities let's go horseback riding
canoeing cycling I'm like dude just
because you have herpes doesn't mean we
have to live out the commercial
he's like you don't get it man I got
side effects I got Suicidal Thoughts
insomnia depression I was like [__]
maybe I have herpes